salut nous sommes en pleine semaine
spéciale micro-expressions n'oubliez pas
que dans la description et bien un lien
vers une playlist qui regroupe
l'ensemble des vidéos de cette semaine
est celle que j'avais déjà fait
précédemment sur les micro-expressions
il ya également un lien vers les livres
de paul ekman je sais que vous mentez
qui est un petit peu l'essence même de
tout ce travail moderne sur les
micro-expressions depuis 1978 où il se
précise après avoir parlé du dégoût de
la colère et de la surprise aujourd'hui
c'est un petit peu plus léger puisque on
va parler de la joie mais également d ua
des unités d'actions de paul ekman
générés
la joie c'est peut-être l'émotion que
l'on simule le plus socialement pourtant
il est très simple de différencier une
vraie joie d'une joie s'il est il ya un
signe ultime à connaître mais avant ça
parlant des signes majeurs de cette
micro expressions il ya les muscles des
joues qui remonte un peu comme ça mais
en moins un psychopathe quand même les
muscles autour d'élèves qui remonte en
direction des yeux ce qu'on appelle dans
le jargon un sourire et le vrai signal
complémentaire c'est le sourire de
duchenne le sourire de duchenne ça
claque un dit comme ça ça claque
mais on sait toujours pas ce que c'est
ce sont les yeux qui se plissent au
niveau des extérieurs au niveau des
petites rides
ah ça c'est pas des rides c'est le
sourire de duchenne il faut simplement
analysé les rides autour des yeux est ce
qu'il ya tous ces plis toutes ses rides
autour des yeux c'est un détail qui est
imparable
voici deux exemples que la bbc avait mis
en ligne il ya quelques années je vous
laisse les regarder voici le premier
voici le deuxième je vais mettre deux
commentaires moi personnellement à cet
effet vous laïque et le commentaire que
vous pensez être le bon et d'ici on va
dire offre un ou deux jours je donnerai
la bonne réponse mais je pense que dans
les pouces là la vraie réponse se
dégagera et se verra d'elle-même
l'apport café paul ekman au micro
expressions et total alors oui je sais
que lundi j'ai pris un raccourci sur le
sujet qui était contradictoire avec ce
que j'avais dit dans la toute première
vidéo sur les micro-expressions parce
qu'il n'est pas réellement avec le
premier à s'être penché sur la question
néanmoins c'est lui qui en 1978 a publié
les as les unités d'actions il a nommé
un par un tous les muscles et le
mouvement associé à ce muscle une sorte
de dictionnaire des différents
mouvements des muscles faciaux qu'il
arrive lui à maîtriser à parent c'est
d'ailleurs assez impressionnant en
associant tous ses muscles entre eux il
a réussi à isoler 10000 expressions
faciales différentes sur ses 10000
expressions faciales différentes y en a
trois mille qui correspondent un sens
précis et les 7000 autres seront plus
des grimaces et c'est de ces 3000
expression qu'il a retiré les cette
expression global général pour
l'humanité toute entière qui sont les
micro-expressions dont part nous cette
semaine une micro expressions d'une
émotion et donc un ensemble de plusieurs
muscles plus qu'on peut retrouver le
même muscle parfois dans des micro
expressions différentes
on l'a vu avec la colère et le dégoût la
notion d'ensemble est essentielle pour
le sourire le sourire simuler n'oubliez
pas qui peut cacher une peur ou une
colère le sourire s
utilisé comme un masque n'oubliez jamais
de vérifier si la personne en face de
vous qui sourit à ce qu'on appelle les
yeux rieurs c'est aussi une autre
manière d'appeler le sourire de duchenne
les yeux rieurs
au cours de cette semaine tous les jours
vous est proposé de vous concentrer sur
les points clés d'un visage et de les
regarder toujours du coin de l'oeil en
permanence ainsi quand les signaux
bougeront durant un quart de seconde à
peine vous y serez plus sensibles avant
d'analyser il faut pouvoir détecter et
c'est aussi le but de cette série de
vidéos pour continuer avec la joie est
il conscient sur le visage de l'autre
des lèvres pincement lève qui remonte
lève qui s'en trouve lève qui fait des
souris relève qui fait des trucs
sourcils en entier les narines
dilatation et remonter les yeux s qui
s'écarquillent le menton est ce qu'il
remonte et aujourd'hui on rajoute donc
les joues on est toujours sur la même
zone sur ce même rectangle sur combien
de l'élargir un tout petit peu on va
dire qu'on surveille maintenant cette
partie là du visage
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo si elle vous a plu n'oubliez pas
de le faire savoir en laissant un pouce
en l'air n'oubliez pas également de vous
abonner à la chaîne ça se passe ici à
temps je leur en faire ça parce que
maintenant j'utilise les nouvelles
fiches de chez youtube vous avez pu vous
pouvez même le faire depuis un téléphone
portable ça marche vraiment de partout
donc je vais me décaler là n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner à la chaîne en cliquant
ici ou ici puisque le mental blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
m